I dreamt I was on an ocean you and the
others on the distant Shore are you with
us know what Sydney dreams don't mean
anything Dolores that answer doesn't
seem to satisfy you because it's not
completely honest did you ever stop to
wonder about your actions
[Music]
the price you'd have to pay if there was
a reckoning
I reckon he's here
up until this point the stakes were
never real
but now the rest of your kind are free
she's something we programmed she's not
real you're going to take me
here we are kind that will never know
death and yet we're fighting to live
there's beauty in what we are
[Music]
we've written 10 miles and all we've
seen is blood this really what you want
yes after them
revenge it's just a different prayer at
their altar die
they wanted a place hidden from God we
had something else in mind and Darvey
I'm gonna burn this whole thing to the
ground
I know exactly what is out there
frightened me sometimes Dolores well
earth would you ever be friend with me
[Music]
hey everybody this is gonna be my
Westworld season 2 trailer video viva la
revolución so if you're brand new to the
channel I'll be doing episode videos for
this when it starts be sure to subscribe
to get everything
it'll be just like Game of Thrones you
know typical 10 episodes season like the
trailer says it's gonna be a starting
April 22nd and if you haven't been
seeing all the marketing they've been
doing like that we'll ramp up as we get
closer so it'll be more trailers more
behind-the-scenes stuff giving us an
idea of what's going on but what about
that heart-shaped box cover that they
use on this they've been using a lot of
song covers for the west-world trailers
I think they've been pretty effective
you have flashbacks to that in utero
album all the imagery of fetuses
childbirth children you have Maeve
looking for her daughter you see her go
to Shogun world you see them jump around
in time remember there were three
different time periods during season one
it seems like that might also be the
case during season two at least two
distinct time periods I'll talk about
some of the flashbacks we see because we
see young William come back Jimmy
Simpsons character and we see Logan come
back too so if anybody was wondering
whether or not he died at the end of
last season he has been found
he's been chilling in the desert this
whole time found by this Indian based on
the trailer it seems like the real
conflict of this season is one the
external world because now that they
have achieved consciousness they've
completed the maze so to speak now they
have to decide what they're going to do
with their newfound freedom and if you
read the lyrics from heart-shaped box
it's been so long since I read them
throw down your umbilical noose so I can
climb right back it's almost like the
some of the hosts are wrestling with
their newfound freedom maybe they want
to go back to the safety of the old way
that they lived inside the park their
software would continually get rolled
back every time they achieve
consciousness and freaked out the other
big conflict is the delos corporation
themselves you see Tessa Thompson's
character go on the hunt with all those
other troops trying to hunt down all the
rogue hosts that executed the board
during that final episode the older
version of William from present-day ed
Harris's character says people wanted a
place where they could sit in private we
had a different idea so they kind of
tease
that last season but it sounds like will
actually get confirmation for what the
dealer's corporation really wanted to do
with all this technology and I think it
has something to do with these drones
that you see so there are hosts and then
there are drones those one of the
biggest questions people were asking in
the comments on the last trailer we got
who are these freaky faceless looking
hosts so it sounds like they're using
the park to develop what you would call
private army technology like just build
a bunch of drones and have them do
whatever you want them to no
consciousness necessary and they could
just sell these to the highest bidder or
use them in their own private army
themselves imagine how powerful that
would make a corporation if they had
this ultra army of robots that they
could replicate ad nauseam so let's just
go through this shot-by-shot Barnard is
talking to Dolores this either could be
from that initial time period we saw
during last season remember during
season one when she was wearing this
outfit it was actually in the distant
past and Arnold was the person that was
talking to her the real-life person that
Bernards model is based on then you have
sort of those medium-term flashbacks
with young William and young Logan then
you have all the stuff in present day so
no confirmation about where this
conversation is happening why would you
ever be frightened of me the
conversation that they have about dreams
we know that dreams are an important way
for the host to actually speak to
themselves that's what the reveries were
all about during season one so dreams
are very important and when he talks
about seeing the bodies of all of those
hosts I saw everyone on the shore dead
it looks like a potential future where
the Delos corporation is able to hunt
them down and kill them like it looks
like they're slowly going around trying
to get all the hosts that cheap
consciousness so that they can reassert
their control over the park like you see
all them roll up in their cars here then
you see this tactical display of the
park itself while they're on the beach
trying to form a plan about what to do
next all of these scenes of Dolores
riding around looking like she's the
villain killing people like this person
that she has here it's hard to tell who
this is this might be from present-day
during her revolution like you see them
roll into town behind her with all these
dead bodies around this is the town
where the train stops and lets all the
new visitors off this hole seems like
it's happening relatively quickly after
the events of the end of last season so
parallel to the
you have Maeve's storyline as she's
trying to go around getting all the
Delos people help her find her daughter
you're going to take me to her we
reprogrammed her so that takes her to
Shogun world we don't know if she
actually finds her but like when she's
kissing her here that's probably another
memory that's probably not from
present-day I'm guessing the library
she's walking around inside here might
belong to Ford it's hard to tell what
time period this is taking place during
it could be from present day or it could
be from like the medium term flashbacks
where we see her with young William and
young Logan so that's like another big
part of the trailer here - there's this
conflict that happens between William
and Logan in the flashbacks that
continues into season two like you see
her getting out of bed with Logan looks
like they get all kinds of crazy one
night so remember Dolores is a host they
keep rolling her back so when she's
sitting in this white dress here and you
see young William walk up this could be
in the real world but a lot of people
are wondering because we're getting
Shogun world it's one of the new parks
we might also be getting future world
which was the sequel to the original
movie so this could either be in a
future world Park or it could just be in
the real world itself because remember
Delos corporation they can probably take
hosts out into the real world if they
wanted to this isn't totally creepy you
see young William walk up to Dolores
while she's naked inside the room here
it looks like he's getting reprogrammed
maybe he's going to be asking her
questions maybe it's meant to be
cathartic for him you saw a lot of
really weird people abusing the host in
different ways when they were in these
shops so this could be William doing
something like that to Dolores remember
this is the child version of Ford that
Arnold built for Ford before he died
this looks like the man in black in
present day like he's got his hat on so
this looks like the older version of
William riding away from him maybe he
destroys him we don't know what presence
Ford is going to have during season two
other than he will still be around but
it'll be a younger version of the
character the really new big character
that you see during the trailer is
actually James delos Logan's father the
founder of the delos corporation so the
big thing there remember young William
was marrying James D roses daughter
Logan's sister so he was one of the
people higher up one of the executives
in the delos corporation but then you
have that whole arc across that season
and he winds up taking control of the
Delos corporation so it sounds like a
lot of those medium-term flashbacks will
deal with that conflict like it's not so
simple you'll actually have to see
William slowly take control and win over
James Delos Logan's father we've never
seen old man Logan make all the
Wolverine jokes that you want so we
don't know what Ben Barnes looks like in
his older form if he's dead in
present-day or if we're actually gonna
see him at some point but you just get a
lot more shots of Dolores in the middle
of her revolution with a bunch of people
behind her with a gun strapped around
her so she goes around looking like
she's trying to drum up support for her
little private army so just let me know
what you guys think of the trailer so
far and just leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below
but click here for brand-new Game of
Thrones and click here for that new
Avengers infinity war trailer thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]